You know what I love?
How cats claim stuff
Mine!
Mine, mine, mine!
(clawing)
Mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine mine!
And recently I realized just how much stuff I have claimed
You know, I rarely get rid of clothes
Because as an actor you just never know when you need
A pair of spiky pants
Or a  spiky bra
Or a spiky wig
And I'm so afraid of getting rid of props
Like this staff
Or this random backpack
Just in case someday, maybe
I might need them for a video
And this has essentially turned into me kind of becoming a hoarder
No!
Yes, I can't get rid of anything because I know the moment that I get rid of it
I'm gonna need it the next day because that's how it always happens
And I'm so run by the fear of not having something that me trying to declutter
Looks like this
But I hate it!
I've noticed that when my space isn't organized
I don't feel mentally organized
I think it's one of the reasons why like I have to make my bed before I can get my day started
The more clutter that there is in my closets
And the more junk
The less clear-headed I sometimes feel
Plus, it's like not even helpful to have all of this stuff around
It's like it makes it harder to actually sift through what you have
And because you have so much junk
You don't even remember what's in there
And because it stresses you out
You just don't even want to go near it
So I bought the book the life-changing magic of tidying up
Hoping that it would help me
Regain a sense of control over...stuff
And I followed all of the practices she kind of outlines in it
But my favorite takeaway was this idea that if you hold an item
And it doesn't spark joy
It's totally okay to either get rid of it, or donate it
Even if the item is a gift
I've always had a really hard time parting with something
If it was originally a gift for me
But the konmari method says
That the initial joy you received when you got the gift means that
It has fulfilled its purpose
So now if it doesn't spark joy, it's totally fine to get rid of it
(Eric speaking off cam)
Yeah, yeah, can you leave that in the edit so that everyone else knows that you also did this with me
Also, what Eric said.
The book also had some other advice that I found incredibly helpful
Such as organizing by category not by room
And decluttering everything before you attempt to organize it
And she also had this method of folding clothes
And storing it vertically so that when you open your drawers
Everything's kind of laid out for you
And pleasantly aesthetic
If you are a freak for organization or just desperately need to spring clean
And don't really know where to start
I would really recommend checking out her book and trying out all of the things
And seeing what resonates with you and what doesn't
I am currently working on paring down even more
Because I just have so much junk and I hate I just hate throwing things away
So I'm working on selling a bunch of old wardrobe and costumes and props
So that I can use the proceeds to fund my favorite organization
Sante D'or Foundation, which I've talked about numerous times before
So that I'm not just, you know, going down to Goodwill
Time after time with heaps of junk
Which is why I'm stoked to say that today's episode is sponsored by Mercari
Mercari is a free app think of it like a digital garage sale
You can purchase items or sell items directly from your phone
So it's the perfect way to declutter and make a little extra cash for the holiday season
Selling is super easy
You just take a photo of something
You put in a little description and you list it
When it's sold you get a shipping label
And you just drop it off at the post office
To sign up for an account and begin selling today
Just click the link in the description below
And when you're on the app you can also find my profile
And if you want to make a purchase
Know that everything goes towards helping kitties this Christmas
I'm Anna Akana
See you next year!